it's the newest aquatic extreme sport
cichlid fish mouth fighting before our
next bout here's a brief tutorial on
what it is and how it works our
combatants square off face to face here
in Lake Tanganyika in Africa they
compare mouth sizes if one cichlids
mouth is bigger the other one takes off
in this case the matches even steven
it's time to rumble but hey that's just
a warm-up let's go to the main event
it's a cichlid battle royale they go
mouth to mouth as they compete for
territory and a chance to meet and now
these wet'n'wild mouth brawlers get it
on is it any wonder that Lake Tanganyika
is known as the cichlid mouth fighting
capital of the world